so not anything about that but i will
tell you about critics
you can't get wrapped up in that kind of
thing because critics
you know i mean they they're just one
guy's opinion
right that's just one guy's opinion
that's true you know what i mean
like like uh what i like about the
computer is
it's interactive do you know what that
means yeah sure it doesn't matter if you
don't i didn't either before today
but what it means is that the people
that are watching they can post their
own reviews of the show absolutely
on the the the web sure page yeah of
course
so what i did is and because that's what
i care about i don't care about
owen gleberman right that's not who we
do i care about the folks at home
right and so uh daniel kellison gave me
a big
a bunch of comments these are comments
oh cool
from the internet oh great people that
listen to this and i haven't
read any of these i'm just going to read
them oh i can't wait to hear something
let's hear something i'm going to read
them live because this is a live show i
don't want to do pre stuff
no do you like pre stuff
i don't know he likes free stuff
so do you want to hear one of course
this first one is from
monk fan 72 i love these guys names yeah
that guy likes monk he likes mug
he says i love this podcast it was great
to see norm mcdonald back
and super dave was the perfect choice as
first guest
lose the douchebag
what's he's talking about me yeah well
we don't know if he's talking he's
clearly talking about me
he is talking about you i'm not on the
internet anymore i like i
quit the internet i quit like i'll go on
my computer and i'll like google
an image that i don't want to see so
then i see a whole
wall of it yeah you know like big dicks
with nails in them
but i have hundreds of others all right
you know let's that's you're right it's
one guy he's entitled to his opinions
and that's fine whatever and mostly they
like the show well good little let's
hear another one there
all right let's hear another one what's
the deal with that [ __ ] douchebag
well uh
that's about you i mean
i was talking earlier about i'm trying
to educate myself
and that is true and i think you know um
the internet probably the greatest
resource of information the world has
ever seen
it's amazing and there are online
encyclopedias
that you can go into and change
you can't do that in the library can you
really you can't just get down inside of
people what are you doing mate just
changing a bit
[ __ ] off
it's loads of websites just clogging up
the internet
by people they're doing websites about
themselves it's like
my name is rupert this is my cat i like
the cure who gives a [ __ ]
and the trivia sites where do people
just load up things they've learned and
i just think
what they wake up in a cold sweat and go
i've got to tell the world this the
peanut is not a nut it's a legume
but my favorite my favorite are the
animal facts
the animal facts are just i think
incredible
this is from a website called devon
jen's
world of knowledge okay and i want you
to think about the people who put this
up okay
that you know not just the fact but who
did it and why they did it
what were they thinking okay number one
you can lead a cow upstairs but not down
thanks very much um
[Applause]
i looked into that it's true a cow will
go upstairs but they won't go downstairs
because the way their joints
don't oppose but i think of the poor
bastard who found that out the hard way
come on daisy down you go i don't go
downstairs
come on no i don't go downstairs i'm
away with joy i don't care about your
joints
my wife's coming home from work in five
[ __ ] minutes get down the stairs
[Applause]
are there any are there any good i'll
look okay
not good
okay let me see here oh
what is it is it a good one it's not
good at all
i found one oh good yes okay this is a
positive one
thoroughly enjoyed it from top to bottom
great blinky 91 says a sparkling
exchange
between veteran funnyman norm mcdonald
and comedy legend super dave osborne
one minor problem the set oh
it's just too distracting why are there
so many clocks
we're not tuning in to see what is in
what time it is in hong kong
we're tuning in to listen to comedians
doing comedy
plus some douchebag i don't know who he
was but i like to punch him right in the
[ __ ] face
okay then i mean i stopped paying
attention
to what anybody really said on the end
internet years ago
yeah or sometimes i'll say something
back to them to throw them off
right and sometimes you realize people
just say something nasty to you
so you could just tell them off and then
they'll disappear they don't quit
twitter
yeah i recommend people have told them
others suck my dick
they don't even say nothing but i really
learned a lot a couple months ago
what video hit a billion downloads it
was a november rain remember they made a
big deal about it no remember rain
first video ever on youtube to hit them
guns or roses
yeah remember rain hit a billion a
billion views or something
and i went on there i think it was a
billion i don't know yeah yeah the
number was
and i went on there and they still had
150 000 hates
right then go to the beatles white out
yes and go see one of the greatest
albums ever put on final
and watch the percentage of thumbs down
yeah and i sit there and i go
i wonder who would give the beatles wide
out
the thread calm down and you know yeah
so you have to start talking about this
whole process of who has the time
right when somebody writes something or
has an article
i really don't have the time right
because you're busy creating doing
things to write stuff
yeah you have to think about all those
considerations before you let those
comments online
yeah affect you yeah i'm sure people
like sebastian
are either off you know i mean you
really cannot get in fact
i never read the comments on my special
right i knew that
i i felt in my heart yep the job i did
wasn't
who i was so i let it go on the plane
ride home
yeah yeah just didn't go in my favor
this time you know what i'm saying
i rolled the six and i rolled the seven
and that's just the way life is
sometimes
i just gotta like sebastian said at the
end of his monologue
if you don't win this year work harder
next year right
right right well like you just said
chabelle had the best special of the
year
he doesn't have a website he doesn't
have any social media no yeah
so it shows you what's really important
he's focused on the crap
nothing he has no twitter no he doesn't
do any of that stuff
he says his mystique the chappelle
mystique how does he sell out 18 shows
how do people know
she's [ __ ] word of mouth it's great
he hasn't he has no social media he
used to call i mean four or five years
after the chappelle show went
went away comedy works in denver and uh
punchline in uh san francisco
he would just call them up like on a
monday night be like hey i want to do
tuesday and wednesday two
you know whatever show each night and
they would just uh send it out to their
email list or whatever on their
stuff and they would be sold out in
minutes you know and it's just like yeah
he doesn't do
any of that nothing it's amazing there's
no website
nothing nothing no dave chappelle.com no
no
he might own it but there's nothing out
there are you [ __ ] serious yeah he
doesn't do any of that
let me double check i mean if it's even
if it's out there it's brand new
because i checked in the past just
because i was amazed too and i'm like
what
no social media profile just please come
back later
there's nothing it's amazing you know i
i stopped looking i remember a couple
years ago with youtube
something went up it was this uh it was
uh you did this is not happening that
story and they told me
to promote it when it went out so i just
wanted to make sure that it was because
i don't generally look at the youtube
anyway
as far as comments but i just want to
make sure that before i'm tweeting or
whatever posting that it's actually
there that i'm sending a link to a real
video
and uh first comment that was left when
some guy
he said some of the effect of dan
cummins is the worst comic of all time
i hate every bit he's ever done i hate
it when i hear him on pandora and i hate
but it's like
and what cracked me up i started
laughing cause i'm like let me get this
straight
i'm the comic you [ __ ] hate more than
anybody else
on earth and the second a new video of
mine comes out you're like
[ __ ] check this out it's like you're
just an idiot you're an idiot like your
opinion means nothing
yeah yeah and that's just that troll
nature they just wanna die
you know it's it's very very it's rare
that you see a feedback
on there where you're like it's
constructive in any way you know i think
he's given a good effort but really you
know i think uh
you know he could have maybe just kind
of shorten this and maybe if he actually
tried and worked on his timing
it just never like [ __ ] sucks [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
just dumb just dumb vapid hate
[Music]
bill you often talk about conspiracies
yes i do
um this may or may not fall into that
category but it definitely pisses me off
i love this guy already
i don't know if this is a conspiracy but
it [ __ ] pisses me off eyeball the
eyeball with you so far buddy
all right i get my cable and internet
service bundled together from time
warner
last month with my bill i got an ins uh
an insert
stating that they were modifying their
privacy policy
basically it states time warner reserves
the right to distribute my internet
content
with or without my consent from my
understanding
this could mean anything from the
searches i requested from google
to the websites i have been to what
rights do we have in this country
anymore
just venting all right dude yeah
absolutely
basically what they've been doing the
entire [ __ ] time
since the beginning of the internet is
now becoming legal
so for all you people out there who
always thought like uh like i love when
you watch like those those talk shows
and they talk about
um sexting like with your
your text messaging you know
i want to [ __ ] you from behind whatever
why that's sexy i have no idea
you know do you think their thumbs
tremble but whatever i'm not going to
judge
or like they talk about skype sex and
they'll be like
why do these people do this why would
somebody who would never
and they always bring a psychologist on
right they always have a beard so you
know that they majored in psychology
right
and then they go they always say the
same [ __ ]
and they'll be just like well it's the
uh
anonymity of it they they they feel
anonymous and
in that situation they they they they
they do things that they normally
wouldn't done well
first of all people it's not anonymous
you're dumb [ __ ]
it isn't they're just saying it's
anonymous they just said it we don't
think that they're building a file on
you
it's all these [ __ ] morons who've
lived the life
of this straight and arrow get on skype
and they stick their junk right in the
camera
you're an idiot you're done you're
already done because they
they're building robots right now to to
[ __ ] replace all of us
and what did you do but they're going to
keep some of us because somebody's got
to oil their [ __ ]
robot joints and what did you do you
stuck your dick in the camera you
you processed it's over it's over
you got to take the driver's test i
won't even i won't even study you're
[ __ ] finished you're going to get
processed just like those people
in that [ __ ] movie with that guy who
just died
could never remember the name what's the
name of the patrick swayze was in it
blood force thunder new america what the
[ __ ] was it called
here come the russians pissing the
radiator
all that all that hatred's gonna kinda
gonna eat you up keeps me warm
remember that ed bagley jr was in it no
he wasn't the [ __ ] uh
the kid who was in soul man was in it
and he shot his friend
avenge me come on red don jesus christ
brian you're a [ __ ] director
do you get that man when you get like
you let that panic that brain panic
yeah i just got it okay you just got it
okay good i thought it was only me
uh yeah absolutely uh know this people
if you want to watch porn
like porn the porn industry is [ __ ]
is going through what the music industry
is going through right now
where all of a sudden the [ __ ] just
became free
all right so now everybody's [ __ ]
whacking off on the internet thinking
nobody's watching what you're [ __ ]
rubbing your [ __ ] out to
they're all watching and they're
building a [ __ ] file
all right you think already haven't you
noticed why
the presidents keep getting worse and
worse and they keep [ __ ] getting on
their knees and blowing the banks more
and more
it's because of the internet all they
got to do is break out their internet
file
and show them some of the [ __ ] that they
know that they jerked off to when it's
it's over it's [ __ ] over you got to
do everything that they're going to say
they're going to expose you they don't
even need to take you to dallas anymore
that's old school that's why kennedy got
shot in the head if there was an
internet
he'd still be walking around talking
right now cutting the ribbon at his
[ __ ] library [ __ ] in his pants
he would give the eulogy at fathead
ted's [ __ ] funeral
um yeah so that's that's what i'm saying
okay if you want to if you want to jerk
off to something freaky i would say go
to a porn store and just deal
with the fact that the guy behind the
counter is going to know what you got
pay cash and walk away it's a done deal
but if you're going to go on the
internet
and do some of the [ __ ] that you're
doing all you can hope now
is that you're going to get lost in the
shuffle actually you can continue to do
what you're doing
as long as you never try to affect if
you never try to effectively
effect change you know what i mean
that's
that's when they break out your internet
file other than that it just goes on a
[ __ ] database
but the second you start a movement
going you know what dude
i'm sick of paying 25 bucks for my first
bag when i get on a plane
if you get enough people behind you
united will now go to time warner and be
like yeah russell johnson
yeah open his file what is he jerk
what's the most [ __ ] up thing he's
jerked off
that is the end of the movement because
then fox news will get it
and they'll just be uh turns out russell
johnson jerked off to a [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] last week
this is the guy who's gonna lead us
don't get me wrong i'm doing glenn beck
alright let me i don't know
that [ __ ] guy jesus christ i respect
those guys because they're in show
business
i just wish maybe they can't admit that
they're in show business it's like
wrestling for the longest time
they couldn't say that it was fake but
now you know at some point come on just
say look we're doing fake news
we know we know who's going to win in
the end of this [ __ ]
it's all horrible